sí
muy buen trabajo gracias por quedarte
con nosotros estamos en el último pedazo
de esta lección anteriormente yo te
prometí una fórmula súper poderosa para
contar trabajemos juntos para
desarrollar esa fórmula
primero observa que 6 por 5 por 4 se
parece mucho a un factorial excepto
porque le falta la parte de 3 x 2 x 1
eso significa que podemos escribir 6 por
5 por 4
utilizando factoriales como 6 factorial
entre 3 factorial porque 6 factorial es
igual a 6 por 5 por 4 por 3 factorial
así es que si dividimos entre 3
factorial simplemente nos queda 6 por 5
por 4 y eso significa que podemos
reescribir nuestro ejemplo anterior como
6 factorial entre 3 factorial por tres
factores para generalizar esto para
otros números de actores digamos que n
es el número de actores de los cuales
podemos escoger
la primera vez que escogemos tenemos n
opciones la segunda vez que escogemos
tenemos n
un opciones y así seguimos observa que
el número que estamos restando es uno
menos que el número de veces que estamos
escogiendo la calle sima ves que
escogemos tenemos n menos acá menos un
opciones lo cual es n - k más uno
multiplicando todas las opciones
posibles nos da n por n
1 hasta n menos camas 1 lo cual se puede
escribir como n factorial entre n menos
k factorial ahora tenemos que dividir
entre k factorial porque hay k factorial
formas de ordenar las opciones los días
que finalmente llegamos a la fórmula un
redoble de tambores por favor n
factorial / k factorial por n menos k
factorial posibles repartos de k actores
escogidos de un grupo de n actores
esta fórmula es tan famosa que tiene un
nombre especial y una anotación especial
se llama el coeficiente binomial y los
matemáticos lo escriben como las
combinaciones de nk que es igual a n
factorial entre k factorial por n - k
factorial
es muy poderosa porque la puedes usar
siempre que estés seleccionando un
pequeño número de cosas a partir de un
número más grande de opciones con esta
herramienta fácilmente puedo calcular
cuántos repartos de cuatro robots se me
pueden ocurrir si tengo doce distintos
robots de los cuales puedo escoger hay
las combinaciones de doce en cuatro
formas las cuales si haces las cuentas
es exactamente 495 tu desafío final si
decides aceptarlo es contestar algunas
preguntas utilizando la fórmula del
coeficiente binomial y no habrá ni un
solo diagrama para ayudarte esta vez y
también te van a pedir que cuentes
algunas otras cosas que no son robots
por ejemplo plantas o sándwiches
y vestuarios